so a couple of weeks ago i was
approached by uh somebody
in upper management at politico who
shall remain nameless for the safety of
their career
and they asked me to write the political
playbook so for those who are not
washington dc insider
the political playbook is this thing
that's been around since like 2007.
it's sort of the morning briefing for a
lot of people on capitol hill
i'm not going to say that it's like
super widely disseminated our website
daily wire has much much more traffic
than
the playbook but it's sort of
prestigious right it's a prestigious
thing from politico
well the the authors of politico's
playbook at the end of last year
decided they weren't going to write the
political playbook anymore and so
they've been trying to figure out who's
going to write it in the meantime
they've been doing this kind of
cavalcade of comedy stars basically they
have a famous person
write the political playbook each day
and they rotate it
so about three weeks ago it was before
the the beginning of the new year
somebody from political approached me
and they said would you like to write
the political playbook one morning i
said that sounds
like fun you know it's kind of a cool
thing like i've been kind of a fan of
the playbook for for a long time because
again inside politics inside baseball
kind of stuff
uh sounds sounds like a cool thing i i
sort of consulted internally with
with other people to business and we
thought this is kind of a fun neat thing
and a good way to do a little bipartisan
stuff at the beginning of the year
so last week all hell broke loose right
the world just explodes
and i called up the guy at politico and
i was like i'm really busy right now i'm
not sure
that i can actually do this right
because like
things are kind of crazy and he said no
you know we already slated you in
we really would love for you to do it we
hope you'll reconsider on monday i
thought you know what i actually did
make the commitment and it's kind of a
jerky thing to pull out like
you know four days five days in advance
so sure i'll go i'll go ahead
and do that and i warned him by the way
the first day that i talked to this
person at politico
i warned them you're going to have a
riot on your hands i mean people
figuratively speaking you're going to
have people inside your staff who are
going to get angry at you they're going
to yell at you
twitterverse will go insane because the
rule on twitter and on the left is that
anybody who talks to me
you know me who i'm about as mainstream
republican
mainstream conservatives as possible to
be as
people can attest to listen to the show
you know and i've been highly critical
of
not none of that matters none of that
matters if you associate with me if you
breathe in the same
room that i do then you are castigated
widely castigated
reviled online the blowback is intense
right so you can have nicole hannah
jones writing absolute falsehoods for
the new york times i will never be asked
to write an op-ed for the op-ed page of
the new york times and that's especially
true in an era when you can literally be
fired as op-ed editor of the new york
times running
an article from a sitting united states
senator like tom cotton
so i've had this experience many times
before right where somebody from the
left
wants to get together or do something
and then they end up just
blown out by the internet over it most
famously this happened with an actor
named mark two plus mark duplass
you'll recognize from such things as new
girl uh and he directs his own movies
very talented guy
and maybe a few years back mark
approaches me
and he says i'm making a new film and
it's got it's about gun control and gun
violence and i wanted to hear like a
good pro second amendment
argument and so i emailed him back i
said feel free to stop on by the studio
we'll spend a little time together and
i'll sort of explain
the right-wing perspective the
conservative perspective the
constitutionalist perspective on what
the second amendment represents so you
don't step
into any into any potholes and i thought
this is kind of a good thing to do i
mean it would be great if hollywood
would
represent the pro second amendment side
of the aisle with some level of veracity
so mark comes in very nice guy we spent
about we were slated for half an hour
i blew off a couple meetings i spent an
hour and a half with him explaining sort
of the conservative perspective
on on the world the conservative
perspective on gun rights
okay so as he's leaving i turned him and
i said listen you seem like a really
nice guy
never tell any of your friends you've
been here like seriously just don't say
anything because you don't understand
people on the left i can say
to my heart's content that people on the
left hang out with me and people on my
side
don't care because they understand that
there can be such a thing as
disagreement
but if you even utter my name
it's like voldemort if you utter my name
nothing good is going to happen
it's about three weeks later marketplace
this actor
in a fit of decency decides to tweet
something out and what he tweeted out
was something really innocuous it was
like
you know i know a lot of you disagree
with ben shapiro i disagree with ben
shapiro a lot too
but he once did an act of kindness for
me out of nothing but just
a sense of decency and uh he's a person
who's worth listening to maybe give him
a follow
he got hit so hard from the left that
not only did he pull down the tweet he
then put up a tweet apologizing for ever
having put the tweet up in the first
place
and now suggesting that i was a
xenophobic racist sexist bigot
right all within like five minutes it
was really really fast
by the way before here before he even
put up the second tweet
right saying that i was the world's
worst person and that he had never even
heard of me and he'll have to look into
his soul how could he have been in the
same
room that i was you know before he did
that
when he even took down the original
tweet i texted him and i said
you know mark i i appreciate the
original tweet i get why you took it
down it's totally cool with me i don't
care
didn't matter still the next moment up
goes the tweet what a terrible
okay so i told the people at politico if
you publish
playbook that i write the blowback's
gonna be intense
and the folks at political are like you
know what we can handle it it'll be okay
i think people will accept it i think
people will get that there's an open but
i was like you do not understand your
own side gang
and they're like no no no it'll be fine
like okay fine
all right i didn't just warn one editor
over there there weren't two editors
over there that this is going to happen
that one of the people who had
originally approached me and then the
person who helped me uh edit the
playbook and the editors worked with me
on it
it went through their entire editorial
process and then
all hell breaks loose as absolutely
predicted
as absolutely predicted now to to
explain how predicted this was and how
predictable this was i need to flash
back to 2018. so brian stelter
is the media critic over he's he's the
the uh
reliable sources guy right he's the one
who's the media analyst
over at cnn well a couple of years ago
it's 2018. i was on his program
and we were talking about the media and
bias in the media and i said
on his show he was saying which which
media ellis are biased and i was like
well
yours like cnn okay and uh and stelter
then said
you know you keep complaining about
media bias maybe you guys should try to
get a job in the media and make it
better
here is what that exchange sounded like
part of me thinks that you and your
colleagues at the daily wire
should try to get jobs then at the new
york times if you don't like the
coverage
try to be a part of the solution as
opposed to complaining about it i mean i
don't know would you hire me
i i i really doubt that and not only
that
i make a lot of money i want to do as a
guest for many months
okay and um the answer of course is no
the answer is
no right would you hire me no you
wouldn't
right would you hire kevin williams and
you would then you'd fire him would you
would you hire a a conservative
columnist to
do the playbook sure but then
your staff would go absolutely bat bleep
looney by the way i love some of the
media requests for comments on this some
of them were like how much money was
politico
paying you right i'm doing it for the
money guys
um let me explain something this show is
extremely
extremely large if you think that i was
writing
and spending like a day writing for
politico's playbook out of anything
but a sense of fun and an attempt to
appeal to
broader audiences you are out of your
damn mind okay in any case
people lose it lose it and so all day
yesterday
politico is trending how dare they turn
over the sacred space of the politico
playbook
to a conservative like ben shapiro how
could they do such a thing
now understand that for folks in the
media left they proclaim that they are
objective
they proclaim that they want to hear all
sides right freedom of the press
more voices a thousand voices yeah
okay what you guys actually want is a
monolithic media culture in which
everybody agrees with you that's
actually what you want
okay how can i how do i know this how do
i know this well let's say
let's say just for the sake of argument
that politico's playbook
had been handed over to a rotating cast
of characters
most of whom were openly allied with the
political left and there had been
not a peep not an iota not a wit of
dissent
inside the inside politico let's say for
example that literally they
before i wrote the political playbook
chris hayes who has
gone kind of crazy is it was writing the
political playbook can i say he's gone
kind of crazy
i mean that within the last 48 hours
chris hayes suggested that amy coney
barrett
should basically resign her supreme
court seat because donald trump
appointed her to it because she is
somehow complicit
in the capital right i mean like he
tweeted out a picture of amy coney
barrett with trump and he's like well
maybe she has this picture on her wall
as though she is responsible for trump's
behavior or as though you're supposed to
turn down a supreme court nomination
because donald trump is donald trump so
chris hayes has not been i would say the
most
responsible or factual actor in all of
this was there a
did i call for him his d platforming no
have ever called for advertisers to drop
him not once
what was i upset that playbook decided
to let him edit the play but of course
not
okay no was it nor was anyone at
playbook no one was
hey ken burns who is an open member of
the left he wrote the playbook yamiche
alcindor who's an incredibly open member
of the anti-trump left
she wrote the playbook earlier this week
okay so then i write the playbook and
everyone loses it loses it right it
trends on twitter and when it trends on
twitter you have to understand
that your elite media guardians the new
ruling class all the people who went to
the same schools
and speak the language of vocary twitter
is like
the the place they go it's basically
like a listserv twitter
is where they go to have their public
internal discussions
and so you start hearing news that on
the slack channels at twitter
at political people are very angry on
the slack channels
they're typing mean messages about
political
management into slack now let me say
this okay politico's management
they actually did the right thing i
couldn't believe it honestly like
good for them good for them really like
they asked me to do it
they stood by it they did one thing
which they didn't do for anybody else
which is that in their pm playbook
edition they then ran a letter to the
editor essentially from somebody who
opposed me they didn't do that for
anyone else
this week but overall they stood up and
they said listen
we publish a wide range of views and
that's important okay but
what the management did is actually less
indicative of what the media are than
what the staff did so the staff
absolutely rebelled people went insane i
was getting
messages from people who i know with
whom i'm friends over in the political
stuff yes i have friends on the left
and i talk with them guys and so they
were giving me like live updates on what
was going on
apparently somebody on the call compared
me to david duke it was like having
david duke
write the write the political playbook
yes correct the orthodox jew who's the
number one enemy of the alt-right
and the number one recipient of
anti-semitism you're right it's just
like david duke guys 100
like david duke well done you're not in
a bubble at all
at all okay it got so bad yesterday
that 225
pseudo-journalists over at politico had
a staff call 225 with the management
now let me tell you what would happen if
we printed a piece and members of our
staff came to us
and they were like we are very sad and
upset that you printed this piece i'd be
like
that's nice now go back to your cubicle
and write that's exactly how that
conversation would go
because you know what as the editor of
the publication
don't give a crap but they had to have a
little bit of a struggle session because
this is how it works in modern media
you don't want your your upset wilk
staffers to go on twitter and say the
means about you and quit and despair
and undercut you with your base i mean
it was so funny i mean i was getting
calls from people inside
politico yesterday i won't mention names
i'm not gonna say what positions they
held and they were like i can't believe
this is happening i was like how can you
not believe this is happening i told you
it was gonna happen
okay in any case this was um this was
reported
with breathless anxiety by members of
the media like eric whimple from the
washington post
like maxweltani from the daily beast how
could they have turned over politico
play fantastic guys
by the way just quick note so 225 of the
there's so many things to say about this
one the newsroom was angry
not the people at the editorial side the
newsroom
so i was under the impression the
newsroom was supposed to be above and
shove objective
factual based journalists who are just
there to report the news
i was not aware that the newsroom could
be so upset about a viewpoint on what
effectually is
an op-ed page right if there is a strict
divide between news and op-ed
then i'm just wondering why were the if
the news room people they don't have any
political angle
why is it that there was universal rage
in the newsroom at all this but don't
worry guys they're so objective they're
so fair-minded
and by the way there were some people at
the political staff were like this is
overblown
and uh eric wemple who was reporting all
day on this yesterday
he explicitly said they weren't speaking
up because they were afraid of the
blowback inside the slack channels
inside the call so people people at
politico
went went nuts maxwell tony was
reporting that politico
was was basically in flames yesterday
people
oh my god the outrage the insane outrage
it was
it was fi it was all day trending
politico is facing backlash on thursday
both internally and externally for
handing over the keys
to its signature news product for the
day to ben shapiro an oft incendiary
right-wing commentator
honest to god and when they when they
say i am often incendiary
wait it would behoove them to listen to
like ah episode of the show
uh episode okay well matt kaminetsky
he um good for him seriously good for
matt kaminsky
okay the the outlets top editor he said
we published a piece by a very prominent
writer provocateur podcaster we stand by
every word in there it was very closely
edited
and then he said mischief making has
always been a part of politico's secret
toss we were an upstart
some of that sensibility is always going
to be a part of this publication so
again let me repeat nothing but plaudits
for politico's editors for doing what is
objectively speaking the right thing
standing by people that you actually
asked to write for you
unlike the coward jeffrey goldberg over
at the atlantic with kevin williamson
hours later says the daily beast during
a staff-wide zoom call to address the
controversy
staffers were vocally upset and demanded
answers for why company brass published
shapiro the day after congress voted to
impeach president trump for the second
time
okay i have a question number one we
pre-scheduled this thing like weeks in
advance
i did not pick today they picked the day
it was weeks in advance
i wouldn't mind it if they moved the day
i didn't care okay so it actually
happened to be coincidence that this is
how the calendar
fell out it was not like they came to me
the day of the impeachment would you
like to write tomorrow's playbook
yeah in any case just as a factual
matter but beyond that i love
the way this is reported at the garbage
daily beast so i do love that the daily
beast reports this
like well it was the day after
especially the day after the impeachment
how could you turn over the playbook
you're right you know the rule under the
constitution is that if he's impeached
in the house but then i write the
playbook the day after he's unimpeached
in the house
that's actually in the constitution it's
article 57 clause 2.
kaminsky said we're not going to back
away from having published something
because some people think it was a
mistake to do so
and then they point out that lots of
people have written the playbook
recently by the way chuck todd is doing
it
there are other conservatives who are
slated to do this on thursday politico
turned the newsletter over to shapiro
said the daily beast who used the space
for a column making the case
that house republicans who voted against
impeaching trump despite his repeated
lies about the 2020 election stoking of
writers a right to feel aggrieved
shapiro's guest appearance was not
particularly well received
internally at politico several staffers
raised concerns about the decision to
allow him to guesstrate the key
newsletter
even for one day one staffer points it
out in a company-wide slack channel the
right-wing pundit has a long history of
bigoted and incendiary
sorry i fell asleep because that is so
boring seriously
i have full articles on my own website
in which i have talked about my most
controversial comments and either
apologized for or explained them which
is something no one else in media so far
like
literally no one else in media so far as
i am aware has ever done
okay if you're going to claim to me that
many of the people who are writing
politico's playbook have never said a
bad thing ever
that they are all pure as the driven
snow that's nonsense basically it was he
wrote something i don't like
and now i'm really really mad he's
conservative and i'm really really
really mad the staffer said it has
clearly
generated a wave of negative attention
first of all nobody reads the playbook
i'll bet you they had better traffic on
the playbook yesterday than they have
had in five years
i'll guarantee it in fact the staffer
said it has clearly generated a wave of
negative attention i fear it's already
overshadowing a lot of great work being
done by journalists across this newsroom
the comment received several dozen
upvotes from wow upvotes
apparently there are a bunch of smile
emojis also
the emoji brigade is at it again
this is especially confusing given the
newsroom's welcome efforts over the last
year to cover issues related to race in
a more intentional elevated thoughtful
ways had another staffer oh you mean
like how the left
would like outside the beltway centric
outlet reporters and columnists alike
voiced anger and disappointment with
politico's decision
huh okay by the way it's it's all
left-wing
they never quote anybody from the right
of course it's all a bunch of left-wing
people hit my gods
apparently during a heated zoom call
several employees compared shapiro to
right-wing conspiracy theorist alex
jones are you out of your
minds you're comparing me to alex
jones and david duke are you out
of your minds like what is wrong with
you
what is wrong with you but this was my
entire point my entire point was you're
gonna lump us all together and then
you're gonna declare us all deplorable
and then you're gonna exercise us from
the public debate that was literally the
point of the piece i read you the
entirety of it that was the point of the
piece and you all went
you know what you know what shapiro is
wrong so we're gonna do everything he
predicted we would do and we're gonna do
it in exactly the way we said he was
gonna do it
that's how wrong he is to prove he is
wrong we will do all the things that
prove him right
another staffer said the top editor was
dismissive of the concerns brought up
throughout the chat but some political
staffers stood by the publication's
decision to publish saying they were too
afraid to speak up on the calls out of
fear of being criticized by their
colleagues that's what what an
open-minded organization looks like is
that you're super duper afraid of being
criticized by your colleagues again
i have friends within many of these
newsrooms i have friends within many of
the editorial boards
of many of these websites i talk to lots
of people in fact because it's my
birthday
it's time to play one of my favorite
birthday games one of my favorite
birthday games
is when all the people who i'm friends
with at leftist publications
send me a text that says happy birthday
but will never acknowledge that i have
had a birthday
publicly because that would acknowledge
i'm a human being born of a woman
because then they would get backlash
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content